christine je me tourne vers vous parce
que lundi soir vous étiez dans crime et
fait divers sur nrj 12
vous avez également parlé des violences
que vous avez subie dans votre enfance
mon aviez jamais parlé c'est vrai que
j'ai découvert ça en tête ce qu'on
m'avait dit ce soir pas de chocolat
syrie parce que je dois faire une autre
émission derrière elle a rien voulu me
dire qu'est signer je vous ai découvert
parce que je regarde tous les lundis
soirs cette émission chez jean marc
morandini
regardez au départ c'est la petite fille
qui se fait frapper
on va parler de coup de ceinturon de
coups de fils électriques
il est la petite fille elle croit
qu'elle est coupable que vous êtes là ce
que la fille que vous êtes la petite
fille persuadée qu'elle est coupable
vous savez il ya un enfant de 5 ans qui
vient d'être tué aux états unis un petit
garçon cinq ans battu par ses parents
ont le battait la nuit quand il faisait
pipi au lit exactement comme moi ça
m'arrive est quasiment tous les soirs
qu'est ce qu'un jour on avait des bleus
sur lui qu'est ce qu'il a dit peut-être
que ma maman n'a pas voulu me faire mal
voilà ma réalité aussi
vous parlez de vos tentatives de suicide
quand même quand on tombe de se suicider
c'est que on n'aime pas la vie
exactement vous n'aimiez pas la vie anon
à plusieurs reprises ne pas aimer la vie
à plusieurs reprises pour apprendre à
aimer la vie ça a été un combat pour moi
alors christine c'est vrai que moi j'ai
découvert ça à l'antenne franchement
c'est un témoignage poignant je sais pas
si vous voulez 25 cents touche savais
pas du tout que voilà c'est vous aviez
été battus lorsque vous étiez en fond et
c'est vrai que moi je dis à chaque fois
j'ai l'impression que votre manche
aujourd'hui c'est vous avez toujours le
sourire moi c'est vrai que christine
c'est le soleil vous êtes retrouvés sur
les mystères et ses seins et soleil de
l'émission je n'ai jamais vu de mauvaise
humeur
elle a toujours le sourire est là et
est-ce que vous c'est ça ça jouer
forcément aujourd'hui vous essayer de
combattre sa pop en essayant d'être
heureuse voilà quoi qu'il arrive je
pense que je me suis longtemps cacher
derrière mon sourire mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je vais très bien et
c'est pour ça que je peux en parler mais
même cinq minutes avant cette émission
qui était en direct
je savais pas si j'aurai le courage de
le faire je sais pas si j'aurais pleuré
en direct et je me suis dit crise et n'a
pas le droit de pleurer sinon le message
ne passera pas et est ce que tu as le
droit de le faire qu'est ce que tu vas
dire est ce que ça va aider quelqu'un de
le faire aa pas parler et jeudi avec des
frissons ce qui me rassure et me
conforte le plus c'est l'avalanche de
témoignages et d'enfants de parents qui
me disent mais moi je remets en question
justement les coups que j'ai donné à mon
enfant elle m'avait bouleversé je me
demande pourquoi est ce que j'ai fait ça
mon enfant et je trouve que au moins si
ça peut aider un enfant parent dont la
gestion famille c'est pour ça que je
vais en famille avec vous c'est pour ça
que ça me touche mais si ça peut aider
au moins un enfant
au moins j'aurai gagné quelque chose
le plus important pour moi c'est
important la chérie c'est ce que tu as
dit au début j'ai dit qu'aujourd'hui tu
étais très heureuse et ça c'est le plus
important
sim parce que y'a jean-michel voilà qui
disait elle a fait un message c'est un
message d'espoir un message douala vous
faut que les gens témoignent pour les
enfants aux parlers cetera
elles vont pas de boucane a rien à
vendre que c'est elle le dit c'est ça
non mais thierry aussi thierry d'or il a
envie d'en parler parce que si c'est un
tournant dans sa vie
ils arrêtent voilà une émission est la
réponse qu'ils ont passé bon voilà c'est
pour ça aussi je pense qu'il a aidé à
vous entendre
voilà ici il s'est dit voilà on a bon et
je peux je peux en parler maintenant
christine pourquoi avoir choisi d'en
parler à ce moment là maintenant c'était
ses poils ça a été le déclic
alors déjà à jean-marc parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui écoute
oui c'est vrai c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est quelqu'un qui écoute
deuxièmement parce que c'était en direct
et j'aurais pas été coupées ont ces
instants le direct sur troisièmement
parce que mes blessures sont cicatrisées
et je pense que je sais pas su rappeler
si raymond a reçu le renvoyer par
exemple un nouveau lieu qui était un
officier qui était qui avait été abusée
par son frère lorsqu'il était jeune qui
a monté une association dont je suis
maintenant le parrain et je suis très
fier et a écrit un bouquin incroyable et
viau n'est pas un sofa et la missa vous
à part le témoignage de deux garçons
n'en balances ton post ça vous a libéré
alors le témoin et venez pas sa marque
au mans balances ton post m'a aidé à ce
niveau là parce qu'on se reconnaît entre
victime alors entre le petit garçon
victime de harcèlement ce scolaires ont
entre laurent boyer on est en contact
ans on va des messages très
régulièrement
c'est incroyable enfin les filles
battues deviennent souvent des femmes
battues
combien de témoignages j'ai reçu après
deux personnes qui me disent mais est-ce
que vous êtes devenue une femme battue
et je dis ben non parce que moi oui donc
les conséquences sont tellement
puissantes qu'est ce que vous me
conseillez justement pour ne pas pour me
libérer de tout cela donc je trouve que
c'est important d'en parler tout m'en
parle de sa maladie comme parle d'un
cancer comment parle de ses expériences
difficiles pour aider les autres et pour
se dire qu'on peut y arriver on peut
changer le passé ne va pas forcément
influencer l'avenir et que l'important
n'est pas ce qu'on a fait de soi mais ce
qu'on fait de ce qu'on a
v de soie noire se répand ses
téléspectateurs de cette question qu'on
leur a posé comprenez vous les
célébrités qui je comprends à 47% je ne
comprends pas à 53% et qu'ils sont
plutôt du côté de jean michel maire ça
ne reflète pas du tout la voilà ce qui
se passe ici sur le plateau c'est vrai
que on a pris beaucoup de temps avec
christine parce que vous aviez un
témoignage poignant donc voilà les jurés
que j'ai pas fait parler tout le monde
là dessus mais c'est vrai que christine
vous avez tous émus une fois de plus et
sachez qu'en tout cas où fait ta main
sur thur de la famille qu'on est votre
famille qu'on vous aime et aujourd'hui
peut-être rien
[Applaudissements]